but a flood go live on Facebook which I
haven't been doing a whole lot of my
theme song the weed store wine is I feel
like sometimes I go so macro I don't
take advantage of the opportunity in
front of me you know thinking so big
with us and kind of what we talked about
over breakfast I know seven versions of
your name and I want to really own this
right I'm right
told you David yeah you know you I said
Andre this morning you said it you said
it differently and it threw me off
you're the one that actually scared me
yep that's exactly we did what
but it's aundrea it's like was on three
of the nine oh two one oh character yes
no stop saying it because it's gonna get
in my head Andreea I've been on point
done I've been consistent thank you but
you [ __ ] me up this morning I was like
do you rocks a sensitive type of cat he
might actually be right he might have
like went right to her face and said you
know so I was scared
[Music]
right Vader Mediacom / 4 vs the 4 DS the
daily digital deep dive it is changing
small and medium-sized businesses worlds
go on the website to get the date
Instagram I'm so sorry I'm gonna post it
all [ __ ] day and just busy [ __ ]
vaynermedia if you guys know that's my
job
dog man and cat kid well I'm in seventh
place right now on Amazon in the world
of most books sold and number five is
dog man and cat kid [ __ ] christ all
right one more time can i play music out
here like that one day
how back-to-back drops would okay like
gym rats have a gym
so like a space a space
capital-intensive the reason this is a
tough business
whatever comes out in your next mouth is
it cost a million dollars students start
like not really like you could do it
ghetto but like if I started oh he's
kind of like that gym rats have gym
equipment that's what I mean so you know
like you can do it though you just need
to know you're on a real long path which
is cool like honestly I know you like
we're almost weirdly like that yeah in
so many ways like I'm very similar to
you and like I was just thinking like
especially this past week that I've been
off I'm like what do I really like I
like it and I like doing it the way that
I was doing it because I was going like
the Christian route which I'm Christian
so like I wanted to in some way be
impactful and so probably why you like
my stuff right like I'm not necessarily
religious but I'm like very religious
right exactly like you're healthy yeah
exactly I like that
yep that's who you are so like the
reason why I want to do is I know it's
like it's gonna cost a lot but like I
have to start get out as [ __ ] I just
wanted like advice on how to like where
do you want to do it it'd probably be
too expensive like to start in Manhattan
but like Queens Brooklyn something like
that
and I'm super into it a franchise kind
of thing like a place I have in Houston
so let me give you a great example
you've heard a lot of my advice so you
can understand this when I hear that I
almost feel like I want you to go intern
bro who started and runs okay I almost
feel like I want to pitch him on the
idea of doing like you doing for him
what I do what Vayner talent does so you
could actually learn the franchise
business if you really want to do that
if you really want to do that you know
how I would say go work for Puff Daddy
or Howard Schultz from Starbucks
well [ __ ] one of the gangster [ __ ]
people in the game like one of the top
franchisee people in the game is my
homie
and you think I don't do this always I
think that brothers brother you know
much smarter you are by just sitting in
the epicenter dude that's the game
always you got too much time you know
hard the franchise businesses 99.9% fail
you don't know anything about building
franchise business you know what you
want to do but you have no idea of how
to have a business here if you really
talking about Atlanta and New Orleans
you make the trade like if you followed
me every day you would understand how to
run an agency much better go ahead
correct you want to run a franchisee
business like you want to build the soul
cycle of your thing well then go work
for somebody who's built it in a
different way but my thing in my only
concern oh my god
like if somebody comes up with that
before me cuz even if somebody does I
can
it just needs that out that's nothing
she's never it's a young concern in the
same way that people want to patent
things but it's not what the world is
really played on there exists already
you know yeah dad I'm not worried about
it all the fact that you're even
thinking that way is interesting then to
get you in front of somebody who's built
a business that way okay like being a
creator this is a master's class in it
building a brand this was [ __ ] like
Harvard like it's happening from your
eyes even time you've been here all
right you don't know anything about
building a location-based business it's
cool when you break it down right but
you have the advantage of my cosign and
your craft that you can bring to
somebody and again d Rock and babban are
smarter about running the agency than
sandy is cuz they're in it watching so
imagine watching might be like [ __ ] that
I'm not doing that so we have to go the
next person but that's always the right
move at this time you have a better than
anybody because I tell people go get a
job with P Diddy but how yeah you have
my ability to put you in a spot if
that's what you want to do you have to
decide how but I could also see you leap
yeah and I could see you leaving here
and being like nobody yeah that's a
vulnerability and I don't know I feel
like we collectively I feel like we
click I got it that's one right because
you you're you're lucky that you got the
experience with the comedy thing I've
know we haven't talked about it yeah but
like right when you get under the hood
everybody's different you know like
right how was that experience that was
good some peeps yeah that's the first
move is are you house are you willing to
really make this your next seven you
theoretically if it goes well are you
willing to make this your neck
three five seven eight years great so if
you if that's true then yes I think you
should go work for somebody who's built
a franchise business I think it'd be
unbelievably ry+
I would even say if you think the guy's
a douche and you don't click eat [ __ ]
and just listen okay you know like if
that's really what it was I know I know
that's what mentors are for I know what
you were looking at and I'm that this is
what I wish I was smarter and had
mentors right mentors will help you your
training gear crew got it you're trading
what you you're cashing in on the equity
that I always promise which is get in
with me you trade on your skill and go
and do that but you're you're [ __ ]
sitting there and [ __ ] listening
remember how much you learned just in
one day you hear I'm talking about
square footage or why that location will
work or like demographic and you'll come
out of it knowing [ __ ] and plus like the
branding social media side all that I
got absorbs so much here
Wayne you don't even realize how much
because when you get to the real world
and you're not playing in the major it's
like a basketball player who only plays
in the NBA and then they go at the park
and I'm really great you know yeah
[Music]
Bruder can't believe what they are doing
you can't eat it it's raw sewage or you
can leave cuz asalto it and hindsight
they needed leaders for my crime doing
so they don't know frontlines Peters was
brought to it those religious said
they're friends for me Jesus say wanna
do it that's not what I subscribe to but
if it brings a smile to my loved ones my
tolerance the only thing I'm bout to
lead and I was proud to be there on the
ground and the brows to I'm coming from
the South I'm about to let's go anyone
that doubt could get your mouth - I got
him now but I do this for my child and
my spouse - yeah drop winner's circle I
have